ok je vais tenter de nouvelles cascades
très périlleuse donc toi faut qu'on soit
2 fasse ses débuts si aujourd'hui on se
retrouve pour discuter ensemble
découvrir un petit srebrenica pas d'air
ça s'appelle pas des threads appelle des
sols frais dit voilà pas du tout des
threads et ce bout de la septième ou
huitième vidéo de ce genre qu'on se rend
compte mais c'est pas grave
mieux vaut tard que jamais qu'elle
proverbe de losers si ochoa en référence
au film dodgeball c'est un thread en
gros sur lequel on trouve toutes sortes
de sports peu connus voire même des fois
un peu obscur voire même inventé de
toutes pièces mais qui sont très marrant
et je vous avoue qu'étant un grand
sportif quand je suis tombé sur ce
thread soit sobre et dit ça m'a tout de
suite frappé je me suis dit il a été
créé pour moi ok on commence tout de
suite avec le record du plus grand ou la
houppe
non ne me dites pas que ça c'est un
morceau du cerceau ne dis pas que le
cerceau est si grand qu'il ne rende pas
entièrement dans le champ de la caméra
c'est parti c'est hyper impressionnant
il faut qu'ils fassent au moins trois
tours consécutifs pour que le record
soit validé et que ce soit entre sa
taille et ses pauvres regarder il a un
truc ce que tu autour de lui pour pas
qu'il ait mal
à
2 3
gatti continue pour plaisir vous plaisir
de cette femme il fait plaisir à ses
fans il a réussi je partage réellement
sa joie après 10 degrés ouah mec alors
là j'ai envie de tout sauf de me moquer
ces gens incroyables vraiment hyper
impressionnant j'espère un jour avoir
guinée à ce record au moins aussi fou
deuxième à ça c'est un truc de colonies
un peu une discipline de colonies on
dirait un quoi ah c'est une course mais
quand t'as pas trop envie de courir
ah ok salaire à la fois drôle et à la
fois très chiant mais ça vous fera
passer de manière sûre et certaine de
bons moments entre amis fait de
simplement à l'abri des yeux du monde
entier
j'adore ça une course de personnes âgées
je trouve ça fou que les personnes âgées
soient en meilleure forme est plus forte
que des jeunes au même sport que c'est
incroyable c'est parti faites nous rêver
on va vivre cette course ensemble c'est
plus impressionnant qu'un match de ligue
1 c'est parti
[Musique]
on va il aurait besoin de couper avant
de voir les autres passer la ligne on
s'en faut le premier il est tellement et
pato mais regardez ça et qu'on plume et
de qunu vous ne regarderez plus jamais
votre grand-père de la même manière
après avoir vu ça je suis épaté alors
est-ce qui courent est vraiment très
vite
ou est-ce que ses concurrents qui
étaient particulièrement lent donc on a
l'impression que lui va encore plus vite
non une unique ne cherchez pas il nous
défoncer allez sûrement sincère si vous
êtes comme un gout fait très peu de
sport et nous défoncer alors ça c'est
quoi bottes acrobat x à c'est un jeu de
mot avec le bot c'est le cul en
américain découvrons cette spécialité
ensemble non me dis pas que c'est mad
max et non mais rien de vaut mais c'est
fou de faire ça ouais mais ça va faire
si mal
waouh attend mec comment il fait juste
comment il fait il a plus de muscles
dans son cul que nous dans nos biceps
des amis non mais je suis seul comment
c'est possible l'armée un délire de glu
ou quoi c'est pas possible gros en plus
ils envoient un bc genre c'est hyper low
regardez ils seront 1 pc dans le cube il
est au calme c'est incroyable j'ai
vraiment respect incroyable pour ces
deux champs quoi c'est des vrais
athlètes vous vraiment qu'il soit
apprécié alors juste une valeur regarder
ça en dessous là le concours de cordes à
sauter aux us là mais c'est beaucoup
moins impressionnant je suis désolé il
faut admettre les choses peut-être qu'il
ya des sports qu'on n'a pas mis en
lumière et qui méritait plus de lumière
que d'autres infos se poser les bonnes
questions à un moment bon la suite
j'adore ce stade je suis en train
d'aimer profondément ce qui se passe
dans ces camps un concours de kyoto
couteau que c'est que cette histoire
alors déjà déjà helsinki entre deux
saisons la casa des papes l on sait on
si on sait ce que tu fais honte à vue on
dirait un premier premier regard d'abord
nous promet qu'est ce qu'il faut faire
hyperion vous couper du sociaux
waouh ça c'est impressionnant waouh la
pression mais mec c'est vraiment
impressionnant
[Musique]
mais quand elle est de dos et berbatov
ça fait vraiment très peur attendez mais
hyper impressionnant
en plus il a l'air gentil regarder
l'autre crdt un homme gentil honnête
sympathiques comme tous ces genres de
personnes quand oublies ton
porte-monnaie un restaurant c'est lui
qui le ramène c'est ce gars là goyer est
ce qu'on va se poser la question du
comment il est arrivé à un tel niveau de
maîtrise avec un couteau n'ont
certainement pas aussi un truc à l'école
c'est mignon quel jeu est visée non
faisait du volley et j'avais très mal à
la paume de la main à la fin de chaque
séance
pierre feuille ciseaux ok faut aller de
serre son cerceau et y en a qui parlent
l'autre côté quand tu le rencontres il
faut faire un bien fou y ciseaux pour
pouvoir passer ton chemin on a perdu
c'est le meilleur jeu ça mélange à
l'imiter et chance il va y arriver elle
va y arriver elle va y arriver
non allez vas-y vas-y mon grand o
un basique champions
oh non vous avez vu comme j'étais à fond
d'or en si peu de temps chez l'homme
raddho des sports mélanger comme ça que
ça marche trop parce que il ya le côté
ce qu'il évitait soit aller vite et le
côté tu rencontres des adversaires et il
faut avoir de la chance pour voir passer
ton chemin bon après les pros l'aller
les promenades qui sont en ligue 1 de
pierre feuille ciseaux me diront mais
c'est pas de la chance
arrêtez moi je joue avec le puits déjà
de base dont je fais partie des reclus
ah bah tiens regarde comment du ice
football les mecs font du football sur
de la glace et des chaussures de bowling
et au mixer trois sports ils ont pris le
pire de chacun de ces sports ils ont
pris les chaussures du bowling la glace
du hockey sur glace et le ballon en
mousse du football le ballon que l'on
déteste tous ses as donné le pire sport
bravo
attends quoi quoi
ouah attendait mais ce mec vient de
sauter de la hauteur d'un [ __ ]
d'immeuble mais moi gros à sa place je
m'enfonce dans le sable et je dise pas
les attentats temps ça mélange le saut à
la perche et le saut en longueur donc tu
arrive en courant sur une perche il faut
monter le plus possible avant qu'elle
touche le sol
c'est hyper impressionnant non mais le
mec à temps mais gros d'où il ne s'est
pas péter les gens vont regarder
derrière le gars il a il a atterri ce
sens fois moins loin car il tient à la
vie comment il s'est pas blessé je
comprends pas il est chaud au numéro 15
c'est hyper impressionnant ward riz
cordes du lancer d'avions en papier mais
je vous demande jusqu'où il va en avion
en papier sachant que logiquement il a
juste droit à une feuille a4 comme nous
et ses doigts pour l'appuyer rien
d'autre non mais déjà mecs se lancer non
[Musique]
je ne dirais pas ce que je pense mais
c'est quand même hyper précieux nantes
mais qui t'a fait un lancer gros le
gymnase n'était presque pas assez grand
est mais que j'ai envie de faire un
avion en papier de tester et j'ai envie
de tester je vous jure je vais tester ça
m'a donné envie de ouf je vais refaire
ce vieux truc que j'ai fait il ya des
années par gourin pas en course n'est
pas genre d'élève et je me sente je
participe
[Musique]
ok je suivrai c'est l'un des meilleurs
que j'ai fait non ne sent pas ça mec je
vous jure jamais réussi à faire des
comme ça de toute ma vie mais maintenant
ça ne sert plus à rien c'est aussi mes
vidéos qu'on pût de vue je saurai quoi
faire qu'est ce que c'est que ça extreme
tux fini à abbas de toupie ça va être
hyper impressionnant ça va être
impressionnant de voir à wade doit la
lancer sur un petit nom mais qui sait
non mes mecs ça me tue dominique mais
non mais non en vrai rapace mythos et
des années vraiment où personne ne voit
comme un gars steve et personne ne te
voit comme un gars style était là comme
ça alors c'est ton truc là tu y arrives
une fois sur cent quand tu arrives pas
ça fait un bruit monstrueux ta femme tu
engueuler mais mais qu'après toutes ces
années quand tu es capable de réussir à
chaque lancer la classe que tu as tu
arrives à l'entrée d'une boîte qui
refusaient attendait regarder hop hop la
durante mec t'as un passe partout à
partir de là c'est évident lucas ne te
moque pas et respecte le contenu que tu
va regarder respecte ces gens ne rigole
surtout pas bon
mais qu'est ce que c'est que ça c'est un
mélange de jeu ça m'a pas ok après
plusieurs heures danalyse bon plusieurs
minutes en fait ils sont tous sur un
terrain en train de jongler quand tu
n'as plus assez qui pour jongler tu as
perdu tu es éliminé mais quand tu es en
train de jongler tu as le droit de
shooter l'équipe des opposants pour leur
faire perdre pour qu'après il en est
plus et qu'ils soient éliminés en fait
en tout cas ce sport connaît un énorme
succès puisque les gradins sont remplies
oh merde légendaire rock paper ciseaux
extrême qu'est ce que c'est que ça oria
du son quoi extrêmement j'ai peur
à
[Applaudissements]
jackson
comment
[Musique]
à
pourquoi écrit audio x est le héros d'un
animé qu'il est en train de se sacrifier
pour son équipe
mais je veux ça je veux cet
environnement là dès que je peux appeler
recueilli ciseaux avec mes amis pour
décider de qui fait la vaisselle
s'il vous plaît eh bien les amis c'est
la fin de cette vidéo j'espère qu'elle
vous a plu il retournera jamais cherché
par pourrait attendre longtemps à rabat
n'hésitez pas et me lève du ciel vous a
plu je suis très content de ce petit
serait dit honnêtement c'est hyper
divertissant et ça montre qu'il ya des
gens qui arrivent à créer des des sports
avec pas grand chose il n'y a pas besoin
d fois de gros moyens pour faire une
activité qui est challenger tekema
rentrent même entre poste par exemple
des fois il vous suffit même juste d'une
paire de fesses et d'un pc portable et
c'est parti au niveau 7 passes n est pas
celui là celui là j'avoue il l'espérait
j'espère que ça leur a donné des idées à
certains et pas de mauvaise idée de
bonnes idées je vous invite en tout cas
à faire du sport à pratiquer une
activité physique cette importance il ne
voulait pas finir comme moi et je sais
vous voulez pas finir que moi alors
allez-y je vous dis à bientôt et
regardez bien je suis hyper chaud je
vais viser l'objectif avec cet avion en
papier tout simplement parce que je suis
un grand sportif très forte mais attends
je te jure je le refuse qu'elle chérit
un [ __ ] au nom c'est dégueulasse
oh non c'est fou la [ __ ]
[Musique]
à
pièces du premier coup